let's talk about what you've done
Palpatine what happened I know how oh
yeah I can't wait to see the movie what
do you it's fun we always in question I
always ask about Palpatine I mean that
moment with that laugh and then we see
Ian McDermott I was really amazed and so
happy that all the people who could have
talked about it or tweeted or posted or
whatever he didn't know you know that
was amazing
I I posted I was like teaser trailer
coming reactions after and then I think
like 30 minutes later I was like okay
now okay so in the last Jedi we have the
moment Rey is no 1 then we have kylo
kind of becoming the big bad we don't
know if he can be redeemed and then you
drop the title the rise of Skywalker
which just sent my mind very bonkers and
thinking who is the Skywalker Israel
Skywalker what is going on you're right
well I the the title feels like it's the
right title for this movie and I know
that it's provocative and asked a bunch
of questions but I think when you see
the movie you'll see how its intended
what it means but in the flow of titles
that this movie had a very weird
responsibility had to be the end of not
just three movies but nine movies and
the idea of having to incorporate the
stories that have come before strangely
is the story of the movie which is to
say it's the characters in the film
inheriting you know everything's come
before in previous yet previous
generations whether it's you know sins
of the father whether it's you know the
wisdom that they've that they've
acquired and the question is can this
new generation are they up to the task
can they stand up to what they have to
and so in a way I feel like we coming
into this movie have inherited a lot and
the question is can we do it and that's
the question we ask ourselves every day
because you know people are thinking
you're going to undo the Rey parentage
moment from the last Jedi well I look
for people see the movie so they can see
what what happens okay if you could just
tell us now I need to I could um at the
end of last night there I did see there
was a pork that snuck onto the
Millennium Falcon which made me think
porks in ups tonight I think at every
moment that we should all be thinking
worse I
that's like a that's a truism ya and ya
got okay and then final question
constable zu vo greatest background
character of all time do you think you
could come back at Episode nine in a big
way
I wouldn't say no okay okay
[Music]